[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: In the last video,
we talked about the developer
experience and how to enhance
the developer experience based
on understanding their needs.
Let's take it to the
next step and understand
how to attract and
engage developers.
To get started,
let's take a look
at the digital value chain.
Most customers who
are just embarking
on their digital
journey will start
on the right side of the
chain and simply expose
the back-end data assets.
The developers will
appreciate getting access
to the back-end
data until they have
to manipulate
large payloads that
affect the performance
of their application.
That's why it's so important
to know your target audience.
Moving from right to
left, the API team
who's charged with exposing the
back-end data for developers
needs to understand the
application developer's needs.
Using the customer journey
and personas technique
to frame up a sample use
case and taking the returns
material authorization
process as an example,
the API team will need to
determine how much data
is needed to process the RMA.
If the only data needed
is the last few orders,
don't send the
entire order history.
Likewise, if only
customer name and address
is needed for the
RMA, then don't
send extraneous customer data
that can slow down performance.
The digital value chain helps
identify your target audience.
Most people can relate
to the end customer who
uses the mobile apps to
order coffee, purchase
products, or track deliveries.
And most people overlook
the application developer
as a target audience.
Depending on where you
reside on the digital value
chain will depend on who
your target audience is.
Looking right to left,
the target audience
for the back-end
developer is the API team.
The target audience for the
developer is the customer.
Now take a look at the middle
of the digital value chain.
The target audience
for the API team
is the developer who
consumes the API product.
Now let's take a closer
look at the developer.
The application developer is
also known as the API consumer.
The developer community
is very diverse.
We often hear from
companies that
believe a developer
community is restricted only
to internal developers.
However, the developer
community includes
internal developers, partner
developers, and developers
external to the company.
Successful communities include
all types of developers
and even goes so far as to
treat both internal and external
developers the same.
Companies with a focused
API product strategy
will look outwards
to engage developers.
So if your target
audience for API products
is your developer community,
you will need to actively engage
this community.
There are three key areas of
focus in developer engagement.
One, understand the needs
of your API consumers,
what do they need
to discover APIs,
and understand them in
order to get started.
Number two, market
your API product
like you would market any
other product or service.
Just publishing to a developer
storefront is not enough.
You want to drive developers
to your storefront.
Number three, adoption is key
to the success of your program.
You will need to define the
metrics for adoption in order
to track and measure
your progress.
Is the number of developers
registered on your developer
portal the best
measure of success?
Or perhaps it's the number
of API products used
in production applications.
The storefront for
developer engagement
has a number of parallel
paths to be thought through.
Acquisition of
developers is key.
The developer portal
needs to catch
the attention of the
developer community,
and the developer
must know how to get
started with the API products.
How do you go about doing this?
We will talk about
it in the next slide.
The developer portal
is a storefront
for your API products.
Therefore, the
product catalog needs
to be compelling to developers.
Documentation must be
complete and comprehensive
for quick adoption.
Ensure that the onboarding
process is frictionless.
The easier you make
it for the developer
to register and
obtain a key so they
can get started with
your application
is key to fast adoption.
And finally, don't forget about
ongoing maintenance and support
of your storefront.
And more importantly,
your API consumers.
If developers have questions on
the use of your API products,
be sure to provide a
forum to get answers.
Let's dig into a few
of these concepts.
Follow the 5-5-5 rule for
developer acquisition.
That is, you want to grab their
attention in the first five
seconds, build interest
in the next five seconds,
build a case in the
next five minutes.
Grab their attention by making
your storefront visually
stunning.
Create an API catalog with
thorough documentation,
making it easy to understand.
Ensure that you have
a value proposition
by making a compelling
case to use your APIs.
Create a Getting Started page
providing a step-by-step guide
on how to work with your APIs.
Showcase your customer
success stories.
This can spark ideas
for future innovation.
Make it easy to get started.
Don't hide documentation
behind registration.
Make them want to register.
Finally, get them engaged by
hosting events like hackathons.
Proper documentation
will facilitate
onboarding and adoption.
Putting the effort into
complete documentation
up front will improve
the adoption rate
and down the road can reduce
the amount of support needed.
Note that documentation needs
to be maintained over time,
so plan on a team
to update content
on your developer portal.
Make your onboarding
process frictionless
by minimizing the
amount of information
required to register.
We recommend obtaining
basic information needed
to identify the developer,
such as name, email address,
company, and perhaps a brief
description of the application
the developer plans on creating.
The easier you make
the registration,
the faster you can
onboard the developer.
Self-service on your developer
portal is key to adoption.
What does this mean?
You want to engage
developers by making API
products discoverable to them.
This doesn't mean you are giving
them the keys to the kingdom.
You can grab their attention by
associating your API products
with a brief description
of what they can do.
You have the ability to
prove API key requests,
giving developers access
to your API products.
In addition, permissions
based on the type of developer
can help you tailor the
storefront experience
for internal, external,
or partner developers.
Lastly, provide the
capability for developers
to try out the API
products on the spot
will go a long way
towards faster adoption.
A few years ago, I was
working with a customer who
was preparing for
a demonstration
to allow a patient to
update their prescription
on a mobile app.
The application
developer was represented
by a firm external to my
customer and based offshore.
Of course, in these situations,
there's always a time crunch.
The application developer
working with my customer
had less than a week to complete
the demo application in time
to showcase it at the
annual HIMSS conference.
Yes, we were all under the
gun to create the application,
get access to the API
product, and showcase
the self-service
features of the Google
[INAUDIBLE] developer portal.
The first step was
for the developer
to register on the developer
portal and request an API key.
The access to the API
product was granted
in the space of a couple hours.
Then it was all about
engaging the developer
through complete
documentation so he
knew how to work with the API.
Once the developer
had access to the API,
his app development was quick.
Fast forward to the HIMSS
conference for that year,
and my customer was
able to showcase
a cool mobile app allowing
patients to update
their current prescriptions.
My customer had done this
by exposing an API product
giving access to patient
electronic health records.
Like all well-managed
API products,
this one required an API
key in order for developers
to access the API.
The process of
granting or declining
the request for an API key is
available through the developer
portal.
The developer remarked on the
speed of granting the API key.
He mentioned that
in the past, it
had taken two weeks
from the time he
submitted the request to the
acquisition of the API key.
Acquiring the API key within
two hours of the request
was phenomenal and greatly
speeded up the time
to deploy the mobile app.
Once your storefront
is up and running,
don't forget to put effort
into support and maintenance.
Keep your documentation
fresh and up to date.
Provide online forums,
blogs, and frequently
asked questions to reduce the
effort required to support
the developer portal.
Treat your online storefront
like a retail channel
and spend the resources to
keep it a vibrant community.
Your API consumers
are important.
Focus on addressing
your API consumer
needs with an API First
approach and make engaging
with your company effortless.
I will leave you with a
few best practice tips.
Make your API
catalog discoverable,
make registration on your
developer portal frictionless,
ensure that your content
is engaging and up to date,
and finally, give your
developers the ability
to engage with you by enabling
them to test their application.
This will ensure quality
rollout for everyone.
I hope you found the topic of
developer engagement engaging.
Be sure to check out the next
video on adoption strategies.
Thanks for watching.